we have until tomorrow comes and yeah
sometimes tomorrow isn't guaranteed yeah
so you have to choose to live your life
i i think you choose to live your life
in the moment
i think it depends on the culture as
well because it looks like in the uk we
do things a bit differently but in
america like
the girls that i know i've got a lot of
family in america they're very strategic
with how they date they will date
multiple guys
and
decipher which is the best one and then
go for that i think they've got it
well the ones that i talk to they've got
it they've got some sort of like
regime that works and i think from what
i understand here in the uk
we still well some of us still have this
mentality of let me date one person at
one time and i think that
can cause time wasting
so i think it's just some i think there
might be cultural differences i think
it's just things that we need to kind of
because it's different everywhere all
over the world like even in italy like
there is uh there are
90 percent of the women that are like
they're such in a rush to settle down
yeah to get married to have kids i got a
lot of girlfriends like in their 20s
married with kids and i'm like what
why you're such in a rush it's a
cultural way that yeah should get
married before thirties and yeah well 90
of your eggs are gone by 30. so i mean
there is some sort of like if you want
four or five kids you only have so much
time to do it
yeah i mean
and 30 of women experience infertility
issues so if you if you want kids like
your 20s is your best bet
but isn't that also based on genetics as
well because there are some families
where the women's their menopause are
like mid 50s 60s
um yeah like so my mom
like is in her 50s she still hasn't but
and she's had her last kid in her 40s
but
um i think what i've heard is a lot of
like the toxins and stuff are making
women have fertility issues earlier and
plus we've all been on birth control
since we were like 16. oh yeah and so
it's like
with all this stuff a lot more women are
experiencing experiencing infertility
issues but it's interesting you say all
the women um italy the average age of
first marriage is 34.
that's that's lying
it could be it could be let me put women
let me put women because that could
maybe there's age gap in
oh no 32
that's crazy
so it's i knew it was 31 in the uk it's
actually 27 in the us so it's 31 and
i'll explain to you why okay
go ahead italian men's are like the
eternal peter pans yeah so they're gonna
take ages to settle down because mommy
is still gonna be there cooking for them
and washing the laundry that's why women
are like okay i'll be your fiance for 10
years and when you're gonna be ready to
leave your mommy then we're going to get
married that's why that than the
averages is 32. do you think maybe it
could possibly be that the women aren't
marriageable
because it's just interesting because
whenever i talk to men and women like
women are very quick to put it on the
men yeah but it's never on the woman
oh no it can't it yeah it's both sides
you don't just both sides like women can
be [ __ ] up as men it's the same way
it's just that like if i need to think
about cultural point of view yeah in
italy like we got a lot
men's that are still
like
very
peter pan's they're children basically
we have those in england
i'm sure they're everywhere yeah but
it's like you know it's this cultural
way that you stay home with your parents
and they leave like they leave their
house like late in their thirties
while here in uk i can see like
especially in london a lot of people
like young people 20 21 living by
themselves renting the house i mean this
kind of job and this and this and this
in italy like really here i feel like
every person i meet like half the people
yeah half the people i meet in their 20s
live at home yeah really yeah
i do think there's a bit of a divide
though there are some who well it really
depends it's a mixture
but there are quite a lot of people that
do live at home with their best would
you say the same thing for a woman like
she's not growing up if she's living at
home
yeah um yes yes
most of the time yeah yes but it's just
interesting because i would say by and
large because women make less money
there's probably more that live at home
with their parents so it's it's funny
that we put it on the men and we say
they don't grow up because like you know
it goes both ways yes in italy women are
waiting for that man to earn a certain
amount of money that so you gonna
provide for me and you're gonna buy a
house and you're to do this and this and
this otherwise my parents his mom until
he gets the money sorry so he has to
stay at home with his parents until he
gets the money if you're expecting all
of that yeah
but most most girls can't get that
because it's only like 20 of women get
to stay home and be a housewife if less
and most women aren't willing to do the
age gap which is like the best way if if
you want to do that is to like date a
guy in his 50s
like you're yeah you're you're 20 you're
29 you want to you want to be a
housewife tomorrow find a guy in his 50s
he'll do it yeah
yeah
yeah but most so it's it's almost like i
we have these high standards for men
that a lot of them just can't yeah that
are unrealistic at times you know yeah
we still got the stereotype of amanda
it's going to be the prince charming and
that what earth uh his name yeah disney
like saving you giving you that great
life
when i do really think that is
every person as an individual you should
provide for yourself a great life and
then if you're going to find apartment
that's going to suit your galaxy that is
not going to be your planet it's going
to suit your galaxy then great
you don't think it's okay to depend on a
man
no i don't
no wait wait
really so none of you think it's okay to
depend on me i disagree i don't mind
depending on a man but i think that's
because of like how i was raised and my
cultural background so
i'm from west africa sierra leone and
like the way everything was done my
parents came in the 80s the way
everything was done my dad did
nearly everything the only thing i
remember my mom paying for was like
the light and the
yeah the electric and she depended on
him but he didn't control her either so
she went to work she did whatever and
they kind there was just a normal
balance and i think that's quite no i
don't know because you're both african
as well i don't know what the setup is
but that's what i saw so i don't have an
issue taking money from a man depending
on a man it doesn't make me any less of
a woman if anything i feel more in my
femininity but that's my own do you feel
like it's a like then if if a man's
taking care of all the bills do you feel
like it's reasonable that he gets more
control
yeah of course i'm going to be the
leader of the ship
someone has to stare i can't stand he's
staring and he's doing all this yeah so
question do you guys why did you say no
it's not okay to depend on a man
i think for me it's my personal
experience i got divorced parents and i
grew up with my mom being very
independent and providing for us and she
always like tell me do not let a man pay
for your stuff yeah make sure that
you're gonna have your job and
everything sorry out because at the end
of the day if something's gonna go wrong
you know how to be independent you don't
you're not gonna need anyone
so probably in all means like
if i'll be in a relationship i want to
be independent in terms that if
something is gonna like end it i'll
still gonna make sure to you're okay i'm
i'm i'm okay with that do you think
that's maybe hindered you in dating
because part of femininity is
relinquishing control yeah yeah yeah and
and so if we're always taught we can't
count on men men are like okay then why
would we sign up why would like because
men men want to be needed yeah yeah they
do and so if they don't feel like
they're needed they don't have purpose
yeah that's why i made i had like a
really bad choices in my relationship
because then i
i present myself like the independent
woman strong woman that doesn't need
anything from anyone and then you know
men's are like yeah so what what why am
i here well i'm here like but i i think
you can be both because i'm that very
independent woman
i
work my butt off i've done everything i
needed to do for myself and i'm aware
that i don't need anyone but that's not
to say that i don't want someone to do
those things for me
or was it when a guy approaches you and
he's interested in you but you're not
interested in that guy well let's if i'm
not interested in them i'm not
interested
there needs to be no but there needs to
be an attraction first off or you know
something that's intrigued me about you
and then obviously like i said i'm not
shut off to it i'm just celibate right
now yeah like i'm not shut off
and the guy that you're attracted to
comes in the room but he doesn't
approach you what are you going to do
approach him
cool
that is how i've gotten
my guys shouldn't i mean that women
shouldn't rely on men no oh no no i'm
saying was that a question
yeah i mean it's like this me personally
i feel like it's about what you bring to
the table it's like yeah for example
it's like
you should definitely rely to a man if
you're filling in the gaps but if you
now like for example let's say he's just
focused on money and he's
just solely the provider i feel like you
should be taking care of other areas
because you're already provided for if
you now you want to be at home and rely
on a man he's a pimp he's a simple pimp
sim whatever you want to call it he's is
not a fair bargain so in that aspect you
shouldn't rely on a man but you have to
listen to something else he pays every
single thing now you financially you
don't worry about a single thing take
care of the house it needs to be
balanced
balance is really really important like
um
doing it wrong i love being independent
i do
everything for myself but i think there
should be fairness like i ain't hung up
my bra
if i was to meet someone and settle down
with that person